how's it going everybody it's warren and
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
marvel and
everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe
everyone right now is patiently awaiting
venom 2 even though we haven't even had
an official teaser trailer for it yet
but in the meantime something to hold
this off until venom 2 gets here is an
exciting new rumor slash report
concerning venom and a new show this
rumor has
many fans excited and we're going to
break down everything that you need to
know in this video but first
if you're new be sure to subscribe stay
up to date on all the latest marvel news
and so you can enter my weekly giveaways
this week is a scarlet witch
funko pop all you have to do to enter
subscribe to my channel like this video
and leave a comment down below i'm
picking a winner on monday so this new
report is coming from what is believed
to be roger wardell's new account
now i've mentioned roger wardell many
times on my channel before he's the
person that leaked a ton of stuff on
avengers in game and all of it ended up
becoming 100
true like literally everything he said
came true and this is coming from
what is apparently his new account and
the new report says
agent venom disney plus show at early
stage of development
sony wants tom hardy as anti-venom and
the main antagonist of the series
now right now obviously eddie brock has
the venom symbiote on him so for there
to be a disney plush show with
anti-venom and venom attached to another
person creating
agent venom something would have to
happen in venom 2 to make the symbiote
detach from eddie brock but the coolest
part about this report is that
if this happened venom and eddie brock
would technically exist
in the mcu because kevin feige the
president of marvel studios has already
come out and said
that all the marvel disney plus shows
will connect to the mcu
so this would be a rather interesting
way to get venom in the mcu
but as we know from the morbius trailer
venom is kind of already starting to
bleed into the spider verse of the mcu
and spider-man is kind of bleeding into
sony's spider-verse as well
so sony and marvel are starting to
really play nice with each other so this
doesn't come as that big of a surprise
now for those of you who are not aware
of who agent venom is and who anti-venom
is don't worry i'll explain
in the comics flash thompson who we've
also seen in the spider-man homecoming
films
goes from picking on peter parker and
being his bully to actually becoming
quite close with him
he would end up joining the military but
unfortunately he would end up losing
both of his legs to war
but he ends up regaining his legs thanks
to an experiment where he bonds with the
venom symbiote flash would end up
being able to control the venom symbiote
using some drugs and he would go on to
become
agent venom doing good fighting for the
military
and something that him and eddie brock
have in common is that they've both been
the host of venom
and anti-venom anti-venom actually
started when eddie brock separated from
the venom symbiote eddie would end up
later on getting cancer but he was
cured by martin lee the alter ego of the
super villain mr negative
he used his powers to heal eddie but in
the process he accidentally infused the
remnants of the symbiote in eddie's
bloodstream with his power
and ended up fusing the remnants of the
venom symbiote with his white blood
cells
this created a new kind of hybrid
symbiote and the new symbiote came out
when
venom tried to reattach to eddie brock
eddie would end up calling this new
symbiote anti-venom as it had some very
specific powers that the venom symbiote
did not have
including producing antibodies that can
cure any known disease and remove
any other impurities within a human body
but the main difference between the
anti-venom symbiote and any other
symbiote out there
is that the anti-venom symbiote is kind
of mindless
it doesn't really have a mind of its own
and whoever is the host of the symbiote
has
full control they don't really have to
fight another life form to do what they
want
the host is in full control and you take
those two and combine it with basically
all of the powers that the normal venom
symbiote has and you have an extremely
powerful symbiote
plus not to mention that the fact that
it's the spawn
of the original symbiote means that it's
actually immune to spider-man's spider
senses
that means if anti-venom attacks
spider-man his spider senses won't go
off
spider-man is able to detect venom
because venom's first host
was spider-man but the same does not go
for anti-venom
so if eddie brock were to run into
spider-man slash peter parker in venom 2
or sometime down the line and eddie
would happen to have
the anti-venom symbiote he would be able
to attack spider-man without spider-man
seeing it coming so if marvel studios is
truly developing the show on one hand
you're going to have flash thompson as
agent venom somebody who is controlling
the venom symbiote with a drug
using it to do good and then on the
other hand we'll have eddie brock
somebody who is pretty experienced with
using the symbiotes having the
anti-venom symbiote basically
controlling it being able to do whatever
he wants
so it would be a quite interesting show
to see the two of them
go against each other then not to
mention if they decided to bring
spider-man into the show
it would make it very very interesting
and probably pretty enjoyable to watch
but let me know what you think about
this rumor that we're getting an agent
venom tv show coming to disney plus let
me know your thoughts in the comments
down below don't forget to like the
video and subscribe to stay up to date
on all things relating to the mcu
for live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof
you